- All right, we always like to close out
with something uplifting.
Here's today's What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music playing)
So, you may remember this time last year,
we did a primetime holiday special
called Kelly Clarkson Presents:
When Christmas Comes Around,
Um, I got to sing with some great artists,
and performed some of
my own holiday songs.
It was fun, but we also
featured some very special everyday people
lifting up their hometowns.
They're incredible.
Do y'all remember Dr. Giles Willis
and the surprise Melissa McCarthy
and I were able to gift him?
- Growing up in this community,
I didn't know what a
dentist's office even looked
like until I actually
had my first toothache.
So I got some tweezers, then I tried to go
into my mouth to pull
out what was hurting me.
My mom comes in and says, you
know, "What are you doing?"
And I was like, I'm trying
to get this tooth out.
And finally she said,
"We have to go to the dentist tomorrow."
I realized right then that no child
at eight years old should
have to go through that pain
and that put me on my trajectory now.
- Years later, Giles attended
Howard University Dental School
and went on to open his first
practice in North Carolina.
- All through dental schools and stuff,
I was thinking of how I could help people.
It just so happened
that I was home one day
and I asked my mom about
the actual building
that I had my tooth pulled in
and she said there was
a For Sale sign on it.
I called a number and
purchased it immediately.
This was the actual room
where I had my tooth
extracted that day that
started this whole thing.
- We know that you wanna open
a clinic by the new year.
Do you think, how is that going?
Do you think that's gonna be possible?
- I'm trying really hard.
It's a labor of love.
I'm trying really hard.
People need to need it
really bad in our community.
So, I hope I do.
- Ah well, it's Christmas time,
so let's get you closer to your dream.
That is the the gift today
that we wanna give to you.
Together, Wayfair, my good neighbor
Melissa McCarthy and I are giving you
- $100,000 for the clinic.
- What?
Yeah!
- You are kidding me.
(applause)
- Love his reaction.
Dr. Giles indeed has
opened that new practice
and we have him on the line right now.
What's up Dr. Giles?
(applause)
- Hello Kelly.
How are you doing?
- Merry Christmas.
So since I saw you last, the
new practice is open, right?
- Kelly, the new practice is open.
Thankfully, I am swamped.
I am seeing a ton of people.
Thanks to you and your wonderful gift.
Last year, I was able to pay
off the rest of the debt.
When you actually gave
me that wonderful gift,
I was able to buy a scanner.
I was able to get my panoramic machine
and all three of my rooms are
active, ready to go, pay for.
I've been able to do a lot in
the community thanks to that.
I also was able to get
a Community Hero award
which still feels kind of funny
to me cause I don't feel like a hero.
I just feel like a
person who wants to work
in his community to make it better.
- Aw, that's amazing.
Thank you so much Dr. Giles.
Wishing you a very merry Christmas.
All right?
(applause)
- And thank you again.
I appreciate it.
- Absolutely. I'm liking
your post right now.
Alright, so we've hit that point
when we usually give our
guest a thousand dollars,
thanks to our season long partner,
Pilot Pen Makers of the Frixion,
the Go-To Erasable Pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show.
But today we've got a Kelly
extra helping of Christmas
for someone in the audience.
So there's a check under
one of your chairs.
So go ahead and look.
(drum roll)
(applause)
Stand up
What? What's your name?
What's your name?
- Oh, I'm Nadia.
- Nadia, what do you think you'll do
with a thousand dollars?
- Pay off some of my student loans.
(laughing)
- You're, I feel like you're
like the fifth person to
come here and say that.
Student loans are an issue, people.
So here's the thing.
Totally do that.
Just take a tiny bit but out though
to do something fun for yourself.
I'm just saying.
- Thank you so much.
- Yeah, I hope you enjoy it.
Merry Christmas, Nadia!
- Merry Christmas to you too!
Thank You!
Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Mrs. Michelle Obama,
Dolly Parton, Amy Poller
and Matthew West.
Y'all have a great day.
and if it's not, try and change it.